ça fait longtemps qu a dit il en rêve il
en a parlé tout l'état il veut battre
mopar on va faire si vous nous rejoignez
à dire à nos champions du monde contre
mokhtar champions que les autres chez
lui j'ai pour vous une énorme surprise
c'est quoi c'est quoi un invité en alors
là on a un avis maintenant vie
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
faire bouger toute la journée en plus
oui je sais non mais tout le web ce qui
lie mauvaise chose pour démontrer qu'ils
bossent tubes aux sites le long du
travail sinon il a travaillé ensuite
commencé sa tp alors comment tu sois là
et tous les matins vous connais presque
tout le sport le matin en redif 1 c'est
sûr c'est que tu es ma mère de mercy
ramener un maillot mais le caleçon
d'études de francine on arrêtera
cocorico
et c'est celui d'hier
[Applaudissements]
adil mon chéri tu es champion du monde
mais je pense que tu voudras est aussi
champion du monde de boîtiers nom jean
ferrero est ce que tu peux faire ça
valait ce que tu peux te faire 1 1
un petit plaisir déjà tu fais un petit
bras de fer avec benjamin castaldi à
l'énoncé et après l'autarcie
c'est parti on y va a dit on se bat pas
la payer jamais champion sera court et
surtout se blesse pas alors qu'on joue
avec les mains tu peux te donner
dis moi tu lui as dit attention vous
allez aller à 2,3
[Applaudissements]
ok allez mémoire et dit qu'il en est
mais n'est pas très au sérieux il fait
comme une trilogie du fait qu'on a alors
attention qu mccomas kg 135 kg sa thèse
il reste plus qu ils se connaissent
attention attention attention les gars à
cacher les gars ça fait longtemps qu a
dit le rêve il m'en a parlé tout l'état
il veut battre motards au bras de fer si
vous nous rejoignez à dire à nos
champions du monde
autre motard est champion tunisie chez
lui mais attention les bancs attention
3,2 ha ha
attention attention direct 2 3
management ça s'est mal passé
trois vols à vue
vraiment merci départ tu veux dire que
je t'aime énormément
tu es un garçon exceptionnel je voudrais
dire à tous les français qui l'ont vu
pendant la coupe du monde c'est un mec
voilà quand on le connaît on peut plus
lâcher d'ailleurs je suis le gars qui
t'envoient le plus le message mais ne
crois pas que je te paie chaud ça tu
oublies d'accord tu oublies ça fait
beaucoup
moi en tout cas je vous suis depuis très
longtemps le matin ouais serdif en
espagne en italie vous apprécié à peu
près toute l'équipe voilà un trio et
voilà donner du plaisir tu donnes du
plaisir et ça fait plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]